gary pruitt he's the ceo of the
associated press news agency he joins us
from their headquarters in
new york gary pruitt welcome to al
jazeera
a difficult day for your staff in gaza
can you just share with us your thoughts
at this time
yes we were shocked this morning to get
news
that our building was being targeted we
had a short warning we were able to get
our folks out
to avoid loss of life but then the
building was leveled
by an israeli missile an organization
such as yours mr pruitt i'm sure
you do safety training quasi military
training to make sure that your staff
when they're in a dangerous situation
know how to react to that
the central accusation from the israeli
army i have to ask you this point mr
pruitt the central accusation from the
israeli army is
that either in that building or very
very close to that building
they were hamas assets what do you say
to that
we've heard that from the israelis i can
tell you that we've been in that
building for
about 15 years with our bureau we
certainly had no
sense that hamas was there we would like
to see the evidence
we're not sure whether hamas was there
or not we don't know
but i can tell you the impact will be
that the world will know less about
what's going on in gaza
because that building was leveled it had
great sight lines to show the world what
was going on in gaza and that will be
lost
our brave staff was able to get out in
time
and to salvage most of our equipment so
ap will continue to report the story it
will
impair our ability but we will continue
to report to the world
what is happening in gaza we had 12
journalists in that
building but all got out safely can i
just ask you the same question that i
asked a media watcher
in our newshour program a couple of
hours ago mr pruitt
does this represent something of i guess
a point of no return
a rubicon if you will for the israeli
military and it's kind of
the optics maybe smack of desperation
perhaps because if you want to stop the
message
getting out you destroy literally the
equipment
that the messengers the journalists
would use
yes we you know we're the associated
press and we deal in facts
so i can't speculate as to what the
motivation was
but i can tell you the impact will be to
reduce the flow of information coming
from gaza
we'll continue to tell the story but
this hurts our ability to do it
are your staff regrouping and rebuilding
and beginning to do their jobs already
they are we they were able to get out
to safety they were able to get most of
the equipment armored cars video
cameras etc they went home uh
is any place safe right now in gaza and
uh
but as safe as they can be and they're
continuing to report the story
but it was a shocking development and we
are working with
we're learning as much as we can from
the israeli government we've engaged
with the u.s state department
most importantly we're keeping our staff
safe and we're continuing to report this
story for the world gary pruitt ceo of
the associated press
thank you very much
thank